I think you use your hand too much by
the way like your hand out like in four
times in episode I'm right right
yeah thanks mom doesn't not a guy come
back Oh Michael
like a vegetable and I see with clarity
husband like my name is Jerry Thomas
I've been telling you
accountants of equity I'm Tripoli given
a pedigree to mean an official my
facility according the works and I'm
jernard the moving furniture 7 deal so
this is the collapse from the high right
great weekend with the guys I hate that
it's over now I'm super sad you know you
build up like literally like months for
this moment all the prepping all the
excitement all the hype and then boom
it's over
oh that's a good shot
it's why no I'm going to win the league
because 90% of people's sneakers are
dorky bunch of [ __ ] dork just get my
sheets ready
Nate I love him great office feel
terrible fantasy baseball player
terrible he's actually he's leaving
leaving the leaf so terrible uh but I
mean are you ready for this I just want
to be right you know and like something
that I also knows right is leaving this
league why I just think that they can
get a lot more serious player that will
benefit them for the long term and then
I mean you've listened to the interviews
this is a pretty serious leak basically
you're a GM of a baseball team and you
try to compile a team that will put up
them do the best basically across the
ten different categories that are picked
out by batting average home runs runs
RBIs stolen bases wins strikeouts whip
er a and saves the compilation of all
the stats throughout the year are
tracked on a website and between trades
and deals you make your team better
you know this year for the future and
yeah eventually there's a winner on top
with the best apps you pick you that
Tyler's going on dirty one time isn't
taking too long dude honestly on a
serious note that can you put there's at
all a hundred sheets were no pictures
these are pictures Gary Vaynerchuk I've
been in league forever from the
beginning from all the beginnings
I am the patriarch of everything I am
guys for you fishers rappers were my
favorite weekend's of the year right you
know along with the first weekend of
football you know and that you know it
for me outside of the family time I have
at the end of the year
in late August this is the time of year
I most look forward to with March
Madness the NFL Draft and fantasy
baseball why don't we do some sort of
new category like on-base percentage you
think what's the thing you wanted win
you can play sighs I think we can
commence little losses out of 500 and
then it if you go to 500 it's 10,000
it's it's seven it sounds good it's also
seven thousand dollars for the winner
what juices are getting going out
[Applause]
[Applause]
yeah this is a different type of
scenario actually because the rules are
not same days of draft rules are
typically pretty big conversation two
hours and there's a good start drafts
you come in all high-energy Ajay's all
the cast up crews comes in the corner
hanging out France he's always on rules
he's big ol disgusting guy that sacks
like the first two hours also the web
endures Joe what was the question
that's good now what that means is a guy
like Tapia who I have in my farm right
now who stays in my farm next year
that's what if he has ninety nine
at-bats this year right yep right when
everybody alcohol because the past
couple years has seen a huge escalation
in salary prices for players I drafted
Clayton Kershaw last year for $64 agent
kept him at $64 you know we have Mike
Trout and pool Gophers back in the pool
or two bees back in the pole he's not
going to go for $50 plus which if you
play an advance we basically you're like
that's [ __ ] crazy but that's like the
nor like that's the floor so we're gonna
have these guys going for 50 $60 so
nothing's going to win the league this
year that's a good question um I think
it's going to be I think it's gonna be
really tight between Gary and stats I
think I'm going to win it I'm going to
win this league parting words for you um
look Nate and Tyler are you know two
nice young men who who over-deliver many
parts of their lives and
under-delivering fantasy baseball
there's no longer you want to get into
those the one player I want to get the
most is Paul Goldschmidt first baseman
has anybody else said that no not
supposed to tell me do you rock Jesus so
easy keep going the best part of the
whole thing
really yeah Delhi B so we did this a
year ago d-roc had no [ __ ] clue what
was going on with a with fantasy
baseball and we put up episode 30 we
created no context all of you were like
what all fog so you carry your dan I
want it seriously i wantam back
yeah let's go hopefully this will be a
better episode I can't wait for the one
hour version of the film to come out
later this month or yeah litter smut
April okay later this month
I'm Gary Vaynerchuk and this is the 2017
Fantasy Baseball Draft underfoot my
Tuesday I'll be normal
wanna win it away
[Music]
I can't hurry up swish every night I'm
on grass where you tell me that I'm on
I'm going on dog championship players to
help everyone so you know when I throw
it out this is a guy who has rings
so first John Lester 36:39 901
it was white boy because Market Market
always friends in common well boy who is
it I paint you have to go in the
interview room
yeah to be a little longer this your guy
three years ago
wow that is way can shoot good job Jeff
now can you get me to see where I'm at
the jack all the way from the back of
the pack into the man of the year kind
of like that okay Tony I couldn't
represent in women I do it and that was
like okay but when I get this up on I
return it to assessment
- back to the old days when I wouldn't
gain any luck now is like when I walk
around in my city they all shall not
tell me what's up some folks are trying
to they're fading a little bit the
pressure is getting to some folks I
don't know if you guys have noticed yet
I'm literally drinking rose' out of a
milk Cup because I'm doing such a bad
job I literally want to drown my sorrows
I'm doing a terrible job I [ __ ] up I
didn't collect anybody I wanted it's a
mess out besides Chapman I didn't get a
single guy even wanted I'm stunned about
what's going on out there but we're only
halfway through I think the folks who
were able to press through next 45 to an
hour is going to make or break a lot of
folks even if you had a terrible draft
up until now I think you can salvage a
lot of your season by finding some gems
doing your homework trying to get a
little lucky to be honest and then
making sure you're playing kind of like
what the market environment is for the
price so if like folks get gun-shy or
they get a little desperate for a
position you know there's a lack of
quality third baseman left people can
start getting that's there and overpay
you have to be disciplined
[Music]
overall doing okay not my greatest draft
ever but not my worst which is always a
good thing didn't like getting shorter
at 30 but I thought I put together a few
other solid pieces in my outfield and I
think I got some good pieces so I can
get ready to dump everything come five
hours from that I've been actually
pretty focused for the first few hours
of the draft Allen's really been taking
taking charge taking the lead which is
what I wanted him to
he found the league very interesting
there's some interesting dynamics that
he's not very accustomed to of abilities
but uh I like the squad I think that the
future of good guys bad dude former team
name of RL me in Tyler's
legacy will be carried on very long and
this is such a wild rap people are
loaded with guys that I got competitive
here we go let's do it let's go early
favorites are Bobby and drew the second
half I wasn't as far as the first one
losing Alex Reyes heard quite a bit but
doing very good about my team is very
interesting auction can't explain it
it's hard too hard to say how it's
different from last one is just
different we're pricing weird last our
bids AJ did a crazy strategy and it'll
be interesting somehow that works out
but still best day of the year great
draft stressin it's really strong got
the minor leader guys that I wanted and
got all the players that I wanted late
had to overpay a bit but I think it'll
work out in the long term I'm much
better than everyone else think I'm
gonna win the surprise Road a wire pick
is AJ over Tom yeah we'd be great I
think I have a real shot of winning
teenager just made another big trade
I got Carlos Beltran we love that I
think I'm gonna mix I rallied a little
bit I feel decent I feel decent okay I
have a shot best time best guys all that
stuff great weekend we'll see what
happens
but I think if I had to pick it to me
hey we'll see what happens
I really love it what it's a great
tradition its escapism it's an I really
care about that doesn't matter
kind of like the Jets you know so I love
that and I love getting sweet you know
Matson were brake react even Matt who
works at veiners in LA Brandt who worked
at my library 15 years in bandar my best
friend Justin develop my brother-in-law
but I don't
see me office that often but you know
the crop and then all of AJ's friends
bear neck and Tom and DeRosa I just
don't get to hang out with them you know
I don't get to hang out with them so
well I love being around them but I love
the competition I want to win I love
fantasy baseball been playing it for 25
years everyone we have won a ton I won
like number all those trophies in my
office
I've won like seven times in old leagues
but there's another super legal we
combine two leagues and I haven't won in
the first four years which is shocking
I'm baffled so I have to win this year
hey guys so that is the episode of
dailyvee of our Fantasy Baseball Draft
but don't tell anybody
full film version coming in a couple of
months and guess who's gonna be leading
by the time it comes out this guy Matt
can you hear me - see you around man way
from the back of the pack into the man
of the year nothing like that okay
Tony I couldn't represented women I get
it and I was like okay when I get pissed
off I turn into a sesame my soldiers
remain it's back to the old days when I
wouldn't get any luck now it's like when
I walk around in my city they all
shouldn't tell me what's up well shall I
get on my gosh that's so cashews ah my
bad - rabbit former career path homie I
just had to get